how was it for you to finance your first
four feature films I mean what was
different each time about it and what
was similar well the first time was a
piece together you know I was from the
community that I from Alton you know
little bits and pieces here and there
and then I teamed up with a production
company in Los Angeles and they brought
they brought on that came on board as Co
financers and that happened to over
about a year in it
excuse me about a year and a half that
was unique in that sense it took a long
time but you know that really was felon
you know many different resources I
think I think at the end of the day we
had like twenty two people who had
equity in the movie on the second film
it was financed by one person it was a
story he wanted to tell he was the
executive producer and it's what you
know it was a vanity project and I don't
mean that in a negative way he had the
money he wanted to tell the story and he
hired people to do it and that you know
and I was one of those people he hired I
didn't have to raise any money and I got
to be creative and everything the third
film joined body was a similar deal only
three people I did dealing with the guy
that gets out of jail again Alton some
Altan equity and then some equity from
the East Coast and then she loves me not
which is what I just finished was sort
of along the lines of the cover up it
was to end it financed by one individual
but it was more altruistic in the sense
of he was living in this beautiful home
it has a lot of history and the
community and he saw it as an
opportunity to blend sort of the history
the home from night from the 20s and
show how it's evolved into now and and
so he approached me it's that I want to
do this film in the house and are you
willing to talk to me about what a
potential story so it was much more
organic and how that grew but I was
still given guidelines it's not like I
approached him and said hey I want to
make a movie in this beautiful estate so
and that was the writers home
in the film yeah Kari always is longer
you